العازف المصري محمود سرور احد اهم عازفيل
كمان في الوطن العربي خلال السنوات
الاخيره يملك انامل سحريه يجعل من الاله
التي يعزف عليها وكانها صوت بشري يغني له
حضور مختلف ومميز من خلال مشاركه مع اهم
الاسماء الفنيه العربيه
كفنان العرب محمد عبده وراشد الماجد ايضا
وعبد المجيد عبد الله ورابح صقر وماجد
المهندس وغيرها من الفنانين هو حاصل على
جائزه افضل عازف كمان في العالم العربي من
دار الاوبرا المصريه عام 96 واسس ما احدا
للتعليم الموسيقى في السعوديه ضيفنا اليوم
في فقرتنا الفنيه الموسيقى وعازف الكمال
محمود سرور
[موسيقى]
طيب بدايه تحدثنا عن سر هذه الهجوميه
الكبيره
هو فضل الله
وقت ما ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيريد بتحصل من
لقطه من مشهد من قطعه موسيقيه من اي شيء
هو التواصل مع الله سبحانه وتعالى هو اللي
بيوصل لك للناس محبه الناس دي بتكون من
عند ربنا سبحانه وتعالى صعب انك تكسبيها
بالقصد ولكن انت بتكسبيها بعطاء رباني
الله
همم يعني هذا كمان من حي التواضعك يا
محمود بس انت كمان انشات معهد للموسيقى في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض كيف فكرت فيه
وماذا بتقدموا في هذا المعهد
ده فكرت باختصار ان الموضوع يكون خلفي
يعني حبيت اني اخدم الناس اللي حبتني
والناس اللي قربت مني والناس اللي عملتني
كاني منهم حسيت انهم لما حبوا الكرنجه
ثقافه الكمنجه ما كانتش موجوده كان الاول
ثقافه العود في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل عام كانت ثقافه العود كله كان يحب
العود ويحب الايقاعات والكلام ده ما كانتش
في الخريطه لما الناس حبه بالشكل اللي انا
قدمته وبداوا يفكروا ازاي يعزوها قطر في
بالي على طول فكره ان انا ايه اعمل معهد
كان في البدايه لتعليم الكمنجه عشان اقلب
الناس كمان ده ازاي حاول امنيه اللي هم
بيفكروا فيها يعني يعزفه زي السرور قوي
شوفوا محمود سرور ده بيعمل ايه بيعمله زيه
يعزفه انت مالك هي المقطوع الاشهر اللي
انا اتشهرت بها في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
في خطر في بالي ان انا اعمل معهد لتعليم
الكمان وكمان فكرت في ان انا اعمل مكون
لفرقه اييي دار اوبرا فرقه دار اوبرا ااا
تكون سعوديه بالكامل كل عناصرها سعوديين
المايسترو والعازفين وكل افراد الفرقه وكل
السعوديين بالكامل كان بالنسبه لي حلم
يعني هو انا شغال فيه لسه وبشتغل عليه
انما ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر